script i have to read it's in my other
book so i'll be back in about 30 seconds
[Music]
good morning susan
good morning dave how are you good good
nice to see you it's been a while
it has gosh i miss those weekly meetings
weekly weren't they daily i suspect for
you they probably were but i thank you
for that graduate course in public
school funding
okay we'll get into our introductions
and everything in a second here let me
go through the chairman's script which
we're required to read here for all
meetings in
in the house and so i'll go through this
quickly and then we'll introduce
ourselves and and get on with today's
uh meeting as chair of the house
education committee i find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covet 19
pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a subcommittee a working group
of the education committee
no votes will be taken of course during
this meeting please note that there is
no physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee
subcommittee and select legislative
staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by the telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271-3600
or email hcs ledge.state.nh.us
in the event of the public in an event
the public is unable to access the
meeting the meeting will be adjourned
and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that's
assisting us today and that's jennifer
four she's our committee
committee researcher um there will be no
votes taken at this meeting as i said
earlier let's start the meeting and we
will just take a roll call of the
subcommittee members so we know who is
here
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required under the
right to know law
so we'll go through the subcommittee
i'll call the members
uh right now the roll call obviously
i'm here i'm speaking um representative
moffatt yes i'm here alone in loudon
representative uh ford oliver ford home
alone in chester in my office
thank you very much representative milor
home and my contoocook office alone
representative luno reporting from
hopkinton with
aussie the long-haired dachshund oh he's
always there with you didn't he
represent ellison i'm home alone here in
concord
okay thank you that's that is the six
members on our committee
uh what i'd like to do is take an
opportunity we have a number of
participants participating today
that are invites to our community uh
committee here
um i see uh chancellor
provencher can you introduce yourself
please
uh good morning mr chair members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
catherine provencher i'm serving as
chief administrative officer of the
university
system and thanks very much for the
invite and glad to be with you this
morning
thank you and i see joe moran welcome
joe
uh thanks chairman lead uh i'm joe
marone
i'm chair of the usnh board and
like kathy very much appreciate the
chance to talk to you and very much
appreciate the fact that
you guys are squeezing in the time to
actually discuss these issues
thank you and i i also see don burks out
of psu
don welcome good morning everyone and
thanks
uh don burks president of plymouth state
university
thank you and is susan heward here yet
or yes she's
she's here on my hi susan
i'm in the middle of your brady bunch
good morning all i'm susan hewitt i'm
the interim chancellor of the community
college system
i'm home in hooksett uh and hopefully
the cat will stay out
and i also know that i see
representative lycus there
she's on the education committee and
represented deb hobbs and she's also on
the legislative committee
so today's dock at what we have here is
we're we're looking at the
hb2 and the merger
information that's within hb2
and we have invited today uh dr don
burks he is president of plymouth state
university
and he has a a wonderful history i
believe of
out in bay run that's penn state erie uh
and
i believe don was the chancellor there
maybe that's
a another name for pres president of the
college
uh however don is uh very knowledgeable
in this area
we also have susan heward here susan is
from the community college system as she
mentioned
and also the interim chancellor of the
community college system
and following don and and susan we will
then have
uh catherine provencher i've known
catherine for a number of years
when she was treasurer of the state here
and that was very important to all of us
and
now she is uh interim chance or for the
the system
and welcome and joe moran i've had the
pleasure working with you uh
as a a part-time trustee when i took the
spot
of uh our speaker and i really enjoyed
that opportunity
so going into where we are today
don could you please start um with a
presentation regarding
uh you you sent us a a short well we
actually got from
from uh uh chancellor uh provencher
uh uh uh a sheet identifies some of the
issues both sides the coin here in terms
of
uh what a merger might mean for for our
university system so
uh could you please uh go ahead and and
and present thanks
uh appreciate the opportunity to come
and talk for a few minutes and
uh i think all of you have a copy of uh
what uh kathy sent at least i hope so
uh but i'm gonna go through some of the
high points
just because over the years i've been in
four different
educational systems and i've gotten to
see a lot of different pieces of that
also studied some because i often went
to other campus systems to look at how
they were working and functioning
because of some of the jobs i had in
academia
but before that i was in industry for
about 14
15 years actually a few more than that
so got to see a little bit of both sides
and how things work together
for the benefits of the states in the
system particularly i focused a lot of
time on how
systems can work on economic development
and support of the states in which
they're apart
in fact starting out in new mexico state
really looked at
what uh how and what you could do as a
university
to make a difference in the future of
the state and the directions
it goes i put together this kind of
list of two parts really uh i think
there's there's a there's two sides of
the coin here one looking at
what the benefits and potential benefits
are and the other side is looking
at some of the challenges when you do do
sort of a consolidation like this
so each one of these items that i have
down here has a story and i don't have
time to
tell all the stories that are associated
by that but i just want to hit some
highlights of it that you can go with us
don
yeah all right did i lose you
don can you hear us yes no
okay yep okay can you hear me all right
i think it's on your i think maybe on
your end rick
yeah we can't we can hear brooks fine
okay can you never tell sometimes with
these things
okay so uh
i'll keep going then and uh you may want
to wait a minute
okay comes back there you go are you
back rick
oops lost you again you're muted direct
muted man
there you go all right we're good all
good
okay i'll start with some of the what
i've seen over the course of time
as the benefits of an integrated system
and how it might play a role here
in new hampshire uh one of the things
i've liked
at in other systems that i've seen is
when they have an
integrated structure they're better able
to
have representation that's coherent
and strategic throughout the state each
of the campuses
sort of is an outlet for their
communities in which they're apart
and there's also the opportunities of
what we used to call in
texas mitzi's where campuses get
together and provide smaller outlets
to regions that normally wouldn't have
an educational presence so
one of the things i like about an
integrated system is
a strategic view and having touch points
across the
the state to address the needs of
different regions
but be able to pull on and draw the
resources
of a whole system so that's one thing
i've seen that works pretty well
also there's there's an aspect of a
unified system
that the governor in the legislature can
work with and and i say this from the
fact that
several the states have been a part of
the universities
have been a key part in the strategic
direction
and setting the strategic direction for
the
state as a whole and sort of a tri-part
arrangement where the government
uh the state the legislature the
local industries and academia get
together
to map out a strategic plan and strategy
to move the state forward and putting
together in a single group like that
provides a good way
for legislatures and governors
and and the various entities to interact
and have a sort of strategic statewide
goal and presence uh i think also one
thing i found
is when there's a unified system you're
better able to deal with some of the
cross-cutting needs that businesses have
often businesses will have to
draw on and need resources from not just
the local campus but
different elements of the system as a
whole and it's
really helpful when they can work and
coordinate as a whole
in a way that allows the system
to put together the capabilities that
are needed for a given region for a
project or idea that they're working on
so it's sort of a unified approach this
we looked at this in new mexico
because the land-grant institution which
i was a part of had outlets all through
the state
and so we worked really to how to be
able to address the needs of the
individuals
outlets and be able to take the
resources of the system as a whole
and apply them to the problems and
challenges throughout the state
and and i think it it really brings the
sort of educational strengths to a
region i found this also in texas
where texas a m had what was the
equivalent of
a um what you call usually the ag
service station or ag station they had
an engineering one
and what they did was they had were able
to support businesses throughout the
state and economic development that went
on those regions so
having a system kind of unified system
like that gives you the ability to do
some of these things
that are tougher to do as individual
elements and
pieces i i've also found
that it strengthens the academic
pathways that students
have from an associate level all the way
through to phd
students find at different times in
their lives they need different bits of
education
and having a way where that's a
coordinated approach where they can take
classes in one place and build on those
educational elements stackable so to
speak throughout a whole range from
to a bs to an ms to a phd if needed
or even even in elements less than that
enables them to sort of tailor their
education throughout their lifetime
to their needs as they grow as an
individual and with their business
opportunities
have i think it also provides greater
affordability
and i think the rate way it does that is
it
provides a pathway for students through
two-year institutions to four-year
institutions
and what where they can afford to
live locally get an education that's
more
economically balanced for the first
couple of years but also be
able to because of the system sort of
approach be able to take courses in
those areas
that lead them to get a bs or an ms or
phd degree
one thing that i think is critical also
is there's better branding
opportunities when you have a unified
system we're in competition
for with all the uh states around us uh
oftentimes the costs are less a lot of
our students leave to get education
elsewhere
a lot of our graduates leave to uh get
jobs elsewhere
one of the one of the things about
enabling
a system as a whole to have a brand it
allows you to compete more effectively
to keep your students that are in the
state in the state
because you can actually tie together
the elements of it and actually project
to their population
what the capabilities are and the
opportunities within your own
own sort of system if we're disjointed
it's sometimes hard to be able to do
that in a unified way
and i think one of the things that we
could really use in new hampshire is
this
kind of informed perspective on what the
system as a whole is
to allow us to compete with effectively
with out-of-state
uh systems i always think that
what i've seen is if you do it right and
if you make the combined system
uh what it can be there's there's really
the
ability to eliminate the competitiveness
within a system
and actually use it to specialize the
tasks and the skills that are needed in
various areas throughout the state
so it allows you to complement those
skills rather than competing with them
and i've found that oftentimes if it's
not when you don't have an organized
system like that
it's their tendency is to sort of create
redundancies throughout the system
whether it be in back office operations
or in the actual operations that
uh the educational offerings that are
that are had
we're working on some of that now at a
system level and i think
what's happened in this last year really
makes this view
much more possible is because many of
our classrooms now
are put together so that we have video
links so that we can
do remote education very easily
so places that are more remote that
may have been not
not very strong in in the amount of
education they could get
now with this combined sort of system
view with the automation that's occurred
allows you to target and put at each
location
i think uh capabilities that would be
needed by the students in those areas
um let me see some of the other things i
wanted to bring up
uh
yeah there's another some aspects that i
kind of like and i've watched at other
places i've been
um and that is and particularly i found
this in
[Music]
in texas when i was at the university of
houston system
is the ability of the flagship to
concentrate more on graduate and phd
programs but also on business innovation
and r
d and then working with the other
campuses
around the state that ability to sort of
mix that
capability to provide the sort of
business support that's needed at all
different levels
and also provide the student capability
to address the
business needs that are in various
locations
i think there's the ability to better
track student progress in leveraging
some of support
now before ross left we were working
together on
developing a common pathway approach in
both the community colleges
and the university system and i think
the potential that
to assure students when they come in
that they've got a seamless pathway
from beginning wherever they are to
completing their degree
in any of the locations around the state
really
provide a lot of benefits i think there
are benefits to the community
colleges in this way but also in the
four-year institutions because
there's a sense of a relationship that
in which the value of both community
college
uh activities and the the
sometimes less applied uh work that's
done
at universities can see that everybody
every group can see the advantages of
both approaches and it brings
reality to both sides of the issue it
provides pathways for students to grow
and learn but it also
provides and pulls i think the
the campuses that are for your
institutions more into the world of
saying
here are the needs of the state and the
region how do we
dress and marry those two together
because i think there's a sort of a
communication
link that comes through both the
community colleges and the
research and development activities that
really and
something i've worked on for years and
trying to build as the
research vice president at universities
this sort of pathway from
this innovation and idea concept
all the way to implementation and that's
why we built the clusters that
at plymouth state was to really build in
this concept that there's
real need for the educational elements
that have to do with innovation and
research
but there also needs to be the
application of those skill sets so
i think uh those bringing those pieces
together is really
helpful i know the missions are slightly
different but i also think there's a lot
of benefit that both
community colleges and universities get
from the integration with each other
on those aspects i also think if it's if
it's
done well and right
it leads to partnerships and innovations
in regions across the state because it's
just that awareness
and involvement throughout the state and
so there's that exchange going on
constantly between different locations
the state
many of you know that the north country
from our perspective has has some real
challenges
uh ahead and i think the ability to
and we've been working with white
mountain the ability i think to really
be able to
address the problems and needs of a
region
as well as the educational needs i think
offers a lot to as we go forward in the
future
and and the opportunity increase for
partnerships
and uh co-location of activities
um and i think on the larger scale
i have really enjoyed and liked in
previous states that i've been a part of
the interaction between the university
systems
and the state on their strategic goals
of what they're trying to accomplish and
i think working together as a team like
that and developing the partnerships are
stronger when you've got
a unified way to look at it i think on
the other side of it
you've heard a lot of issues about
and i just was reading something about
the various past trustees
wrote and and they're all right i mean
there are challenges with this
i think it would require the legislature
to be
probably more engaged with the actual
activities that are going on
in the university system as a whole but
i look at that as a positive from a
partnership
side so i think if we don't do it right
and i've seen it not done right
i've seen community colleges be
relegated to some
part that doesn't really get the
attention it's needed
i've also seen another approach like at
penn state
where essentially penn state was a
mixture of
a really well-known
research institution with a huge
research budget and with many graduate
programs
mixed with campuses all throughout the
state
that originally started as one year and
two-year campuses
and many of them went on to become
four-year institutions but the strength
of having the backbone
of the main campus
with the campuses that around the state
i was particularly at penn state barron
allowed us to do development and
opportunities
that we would have never had otherwise
we have developed the whole engineering
program it became very popular
we took a research park we had 120 acres
we worked with the maine university
system to set that up we acquired the
property
uh we started working with companies
uh by time i had left uh it was a
financially beneficial to the university
but the research park was completely
full
of companies that were working in there
developing new ideas for the region
so i think the the models where i've
seen it work
they take a lot of the the
items that you could not afford to do
individually at the campuses
and combining them with the strengths of
having a strong
sort of central uh capability
at the at flagship at the flagship
university
makes it so that we in essence had a lot
of strength and we could have
gone as as penn state barron we grew to
the point where we could have been a
stand-alone campus and not been a part
of the system
and i'll admit there's the downside of
it is
you can feel like you don't have as much
of a say
in what you're doing but on the other
side of it is when you have something
you want to do
you've got the background and support of
the entire system
in what you're trying to do and so i i
was able to build a building towards the
end there
that was unique through a lot of
industry
corp universities at least our size
i was able to build a building that had
offices and suites for businesses
at the same time it had classrooms right
beside them
for education and so it sort of bridged
that
world between the research park we had
built with the
community needs and the educational
needs
and the specific research needs and
companies from all over the world
came and joined that so i i i think
um there are downsides to it if we're
not careful
i think we need to always watch
that each mission is being addressed and
i think that's kind of stated in the
in the end there i think it's easy
sometimes
to uh and it's even easy to do that
within the system as it exists today
it's easy to sort of put too much
emphasis on the flagship and not enough
on the individual campuses but i think
the partnership with the legislature can
be really positive
i mean you're not really giving away
everything
you've got control over everything in a
way by
the the way you fund things and i think
there are options within that of how you
do that to make sure that
the resources are getting where you need
them to be and
we're doing strategically what is most
useful for the
university as a whole there can be it
can become a bureaucracy
penn state became that uh and they had
to reevaluate about
say three or four years ago they went
through and relooked at everything they
were doing
to be able to streamline their
operations
i but i think when you look at it i'll
look at
two systems that are comparable in uh
in pennsylvania one's the pasi system
which essentially is a state system a
lot of people don't realize penn state's
actually the largest private university
in the country
and what the pasi system did was
had independent branches throughout the
state that were linked together
with with
this central system head
and they functioned pretty much
autonomously over that time
penn state with their one university
concept which was a united system that
we're talking about here
had two-year one-year and four-year
institutions
all throughout the state linked together
as one system
and if you look at it now you've got
penn state
some very successful campuses across the
the state helping in so many different
areas
the development of pennsylvania largely
supported now
by the legislature because they see
the value of the components that are in
those various parts of the state
but you've got the passage system
which was state funded and supported
and it's now looking at how it's going
to consolidate
the individual groups of campuses
[Music]
for their future survival and
if i i think sometimes if they had
addressed the issue earlier of how they
work together as a system
in the whole they would have been a
competitor to penn state rather than a
tremendous
laggard within the state now where
they're they're discussing what they can
actually offer anymore so i i think
there's just sort of this looking ahead
certainly
higher ed is in a crisis phase right now
across the country
but it's been it's been those that have
looked ahead to what the future
brings before it happens uh
like the passage system waited too long
and
suffered in in that realm
whereas penn state which actually has a
two-year community college is a part of
it
that's working very well uh
unified and built a backbone and back
office systems
that supported each of the campuses well
and allowed the systems
and the campuses to really be strong
partners with their community
in a way that they could draw on
resources and capabilities throughout
the
penn state system so um
i think i said enough but i just wanted
to
hit some highlights as i said there's
there's stories to go with each of the
points that i brought down
uh i personally am not either pro or
against consolidation but i thought
when i i always like to see the benefits
of both sides of the coin
and personally in the situation we are
in now
i see that there are some real benefits
as we go forward in doing the
consolidation
thank you very much uh dr burks uh i
have some questions but i'm gonna hold
my questions back and i'll probably
call you up on on the phone and ask you
a little bit about the commonwealth
system
and penn state being within that system
which involves temple university and
and pitt and and and lincoln uh
but within the penn state i'm really
interested in knowing how they resolve
the issue of
credit transfers uh that traditionally
in our system have been approved by the
program
or the department and how you were able
to arrive
at a a course 101
in in uh at your
your penn state major campus there and
then where you were
out in erie the same credit course
it met the same standards etc and was
accepted from one
of the 20 odd penn state uh locations so
i'd like to talk to you about that a
little later uh i'll open this up to a
few other questions that may come and
then we're going to move right into
susan heward
yes represent ellison uh
thank you don for for the presentation i
just ha
i have one which has been on the
forefront of my mind since we started
this
would you have a sense of what the time
frame is to try to put
the systems together given the
complicated issues that we're all
dealing with
uh that's a good question i will tell
you this there's two ways to do this
and i've seen this in the pennsylvania
system
which i think representative ladd
brought up
pretty well one
the pennsylvania apache system studied
it for years
and was unable to really to come to
any agreement before it was too late and
so they found themselves in kind of a
bad situation i think you do it in
phases
and steps i think the the step of
making a board that's really working on
and
if there's one thing i would do maybe
in doing this i think the time frame of
putting together a board
makes sense as soon as possible in fact
i think there should be a group of
individuals from both of the campuses
working together to sort of
map this out and map how this works um
i think i would if you didn't call it a
board you'd definitely put a
group of people together that were
interested and knowledgeable about
education and could be a part of it so i
think
i think the track you're on makes sense
i don't think you're
i don't think you're moving ahead of the
time frame
that it takes to really study this and
do it right
but i think you're launching it and i
think launching it is very important
because
the passy system played with it for too
long and therefore lost the aspect of
being able to do it
i think just a quick answer to rick
ladd's question
because i think it's a really good one
and it's one i'm working on with the
university of maine now is
how you do accreditation across the
whole system
and that is the beauty of the penn state
system is
you enter any campus and it's just like
you're in
any campus in other words everything
translates right on through
the graduation rate of students that and
many students
would start at an individual campus and
plan on going to the main campus
and would end up staying at the
individual campus because they really
got grounded and got the education they
want
wanted but any student who wanted the
transfer
was was automatically admitted to the
other
in the penn state main campus so just
you got into one you got into another
now you may not be able to succeed but
87 of those that
did that graduated uh that came from the
individual campuses so
it had a graduation rate that wasn't a
whole lot different than it was for the
those that had gone up through the main
campus
thank you
you're muted you're muted rick
yeah we'll go with representative moffat
with a question but i'd like to also
you know hold back for some of our
questions to the latter part so that we
could
uh get susan hewitt in and i'd like to
hear from catherine
fincher and joe moran as well here so uh
go ahead representative moffatt sure
thank you mr chairman
and uh welcome dr burks uh real quick i
spent many years in the university
system
mostly at plymouth and i also spent uh
over 20 years in the cc
snh system so i spent a lot of time in
both systems
a difference currently between the
systems but you mentioned
funding ccsnh has been
essentially a state agency where the
legislature could
could see the line items usna it's a
little bit different
more autonomy there there's so many
pieces
to this but let me just ask you uh one
question
uh as you see this moving forward in
some fashion
again the ccs and h folks of which i was
one
were in our essentially state employees
the usnh folks as i mentioned have a
little more autonomy so
if or however this merger comes about if
or when
uh do you see everyone in this merged
situation as being a a state employee
on the ccs nh model or having more
autonomy and separation as per the us
nh model i think that's determinate
determination that the legislature can
make i
i found interestingly when i was at penn
state
that there were individuals in different
plans
uh so although there was
one system it had a variety of
approaches that it used for
how it did things so i think
i think that's something to be discussed
and worked on
as things move forward i think there
are benefits to making the system as
coherently
united as possible but i think there
is room for flexibility as i've seen in
other systems
so i mean when i was at new mexico state
it was essentially
different a different system uh the
community colleges were
but they were still a part of the system
as a whole and still part strategically
of what we were trying to do
so i think you've got some flexibility
on that
in that line that that's a good question
and perhaps when we get to some of the
other speakers they can also
address it represent my our last one and
then we're going to go to
doctor hewitt just briefly uh uh doctor
the question i have is a management
question currently
we have uh in our system as i understand
it
each president of the college reports
directly to the board of trustees of the
university system
with a fairly weak chancellor system
in your experience what has been the
management
structure in some of the successful
systems that you've been in
as it relates to presence of colleges
versus a stronger ceo
uh in a as a from a chancellor
perspective
i i've seen every mixture of that
if you want to know uh i personally like
the one where
the presidents report directly to the
board
but i know there's a lot that think that
should be report directly to a
ceo so i have seen it work
where when i was at university of
houston the presidents did support
did report to the ceo but each of the
campuses
had was given a lot of autonomy by the
legislature
so they got separate line item funding
and everything like that
so it was kind of a mixed mode i i was
sold at penn state where
the campuses were really aggregated
under
a certain campus office but which you
had
direct access to the to the
uh board and also to
the uh president so um
there's so many different ways to make
it work uh
i know joe's got a particular feeling
about what it should be
and we're kind of at look at it a little
bit differently that way but
it works both ways it just has to be
done in a way that
really allows you to share this at the
strategy as a whole across the system
and be able to allocate the resources
and the particularly back office
consolidation operations that you need
to do
thank you thank you very much i think
this is a real important issue and i
that's uh it's some some of us
i guess i'm a person that believes a
little bit different that
uh differently that you need a strong
ceo
managing um where are you going
and i i think that buck has to stop
somewhere
uh so but i'd like now if we can rick
dave you know just a really quick
specific question
make it click dave no we'll do we'll do
rick thanks
don thanks very much for um for your
time this morning
um you had mentioned that um that
plymouth state
um is um you know is doing some
partnerships with or work working
together with
white mountain community college and i
was just wondering what sort of
challenges or difficulties
you you've run into with that that
um you know couldn't be resolved by
you know working things out with chuck
but uh but might be able to be remedied
through a merger
yeah i'll tell you first of all chuck's
been great to work with
and uh we both want the same thing
i think where we get into an issue is
there's no framework
really to do the type of integration
that we want to do we're certainly
sharing back and forth on things but
chuck and i have talked about how much
further we could go
in this if we had a closer association
with each other
uh particularly one of the things that
you need to resolve are the different
faculties in the group and the different
ways that those faculties interact with
each other having a unified approach
allows you to think as a whole
and i think you run into even things you
don't even realize you run into
as separate systems that
inhibit the movement of things you
really want to do so even though you
have
a president the two presidents that
really want
to actually work extremely tightly
together
uh it seems like the issues are just
hard when you're not one coherent system
that's just the way it works thank you
very much
dr burks uh uh i think we're gonna
transition now
into the community college system with
uh dr heward
welcome and um go for it
thank you very much representative ladd
um just a little bit about my background
i've taught from grade six through uh
graduate school
i've been part of the suny system the
connecticut community college system
and for 11 years now here in new
hampshire first as president
and then i thought i retired and i'm
learning the new hampshire way is that
one
doesn't really retire so when dr gatel
went off to
uh bryant university i've stepped in
until the end of june
so a number of comments for you i really
appreciate dr burks's
remarks and agree with quite a bit of of
what he had to say and i
appreciated his underscoring the need to
value
the voice of the community colleges and
i know that our system has shed
information about mergers with you and
that's the first place
where community colleges experience a
problem
is that in short order our voice is
diminished
or all together out
so when you ask the question of what are
the policy issues here
for me that's the initial challenge for
the legislature and frankly for the new
board that will be created
it's one thing to say we're going to
take five members from the community
college board five members from the
university board
five independents and eight ex officios
already from that
arrangement some of you have community
college experience
and you realize what happens on our
campuses is different
and again dr burke acknowledged that
there is a difference in the missions
and how we fulfill those missions is
slightly different too
uh the whole notion of how are we going
to prepare for this
i don't object at all to the notion of
one board
and unifying the systems but there are
different ways of
of unifying the systems we can look at
what just happened in vermont
where the you know the community college
of vermont
is sitting along with the four-year
colleges
but it still remains its own entity
in part because it's organized
differently than
the university system and i would make
that comment
about the organization that we have in
our state
the seven community colleges do each
have a president
but they report up to a chancellor uh to
a ceo
if you will and much of what happens in
the system
has been organized in such a way to uh
to be efficient so there's one instance
of the student management
system uh we use banner currently
um eight years ago there were seven
instances and so even having students
move within our own system was difficult
well we have you know fixed that
um and i i raised that system as an
example of pieces that will have to be
dealt with and i really encourage
um some thoughtful planning i again
agree with dr burke's i have looked at
what happens in systems where actions
are taken and insufficient planning is
underway
i think you can do both simultaneously
i describe myself as a refugee from
connecticut
uh because when i came in in 2010
the the whole merger idea was beginning
and here we are 11 years later
and it it still is not any place near
being complete one of my side jobs is
i'm a commissioner for
uh neche i know you're going to hear
from barbara brittingham the recently
retired president of our regional
accrediting organization
but i will say that what has happened in
connecticut
is a great display of a lack of planning
there's some wonderful ideas and there's
been
very little activity that involves all
of the parties that need to be involved
when we talk about becoming one system
if what we're ultimately going to do is
go for one accreditation
there are lots of pieces to that
beginning with mission so as you think
about this as legislators please think
about
who's on that board how that board
operates and how it is
that the missions of both entities are
sustained
and i'm going to get into some gory
details on
on academics so i'm i'm going to think
about you
you put the two entities the university
system
and the community college system
together okay
so by accreditation it's the faculty
that has responsibility for the
curriculum
who's going to make different decisions
i'll give you an example that still
stays with me probably five years after
it happened
there was a young man who graduated from
manchester community college he
graduated when he was
40. and he had a real interest in going
into research and i've no doubt at some
point
he will earn a phd because he's he's
gifted and a really talented student
he wanted to go back to the university
of new hampshire
and i'm not picking on the university um
and we were all surprised to learn that
because he had a less than stellar
experience when he academic experience
i'll say when he was at unh when he was
and by his own definition of stupid and
majoring in alcohol
he ended up on academic probation
so now here he is at 40. he's a dad he
has two kids
he knows what he wants and he wants to
go back to the university
there's no academic amnesty program so
had that man gone back to the university
he would have gone from having the 4.0
he had in the community college system
to the 0.6 academic gpa he had
more than 20 years earlier and i only
point that out
because there's a difference in the
mission of our two systems
we are you know the college is a second
third and fourth
chances and we have what are called
academic amnesty
programs so frankly if you screw up but
then you
decide you want to come back and you
have a a direction and so on there's an
opportunity
for you well as our
unified system moves on i want those
opportunities
to exist if we look at what happened
in in at the university of alaska
system as time went on there were fewer
community college students
and why was that well first because the
tuition became less
affordable but secondly because of how
as you try to unify systems and policies
those of us who deal with i'll call them
i'll use the statistical term
outliers our situations
are not the majority situations and
therefore they're not necessarily
thought about um i think everybody's
entering into this
uh with good faith and good intentions
but how this will play out
will be a matter of the kinds of
planning and the people who are involved
in the planning um let's talk about
admissions for a minute because as the
the governor talks about it you know he
wants to see people
admitted and then able to move in the
within the
system the community colleges are open
admission so sometimes people coming in
the door to the community college
have a high school diploma but it
doesn't reflect
excellent academic preparation we are
set up
to help people succeed in those
situations and we've done
quite a bit of work i know uh other
sessions the education committee has
heard about
the move from remedial work to
co-requisite
uh work so that we're not losing people
i'm i'm not proud to tell you that
if we go back you know six years and we
look at
students in remedial courses that the
pass rate out of remedial math and
english
into college level courses was about
seven or eight percent
uh that actually was about the national
average
and having switched to a co-requisite
model we're seeing a much much higher
level of success of people who come in
with um inadequate preparation
i've seen situations where someone has
come in the door and wants to be a nurse
and starts off in remedial courses
and has to move all the way through
well what's going to happen if this
person has applied for admissions
in nursing how are you going to make the
decision about whether this individual
who clearly
is not prepared at this moment has that
opportunity nursing
and healthcare are one of the few places
where the community college actually has
selective admissions but i worry about
things like
a student applies to be in a nursing
program who's going to make the decision
as to whether they
go into a community college-based
asn program or they go into a four-year
program
you know how is it that you're going to
preserve the options for students so
that they can in fact
uh move through another example
we have a co-location situation
between keene state college and
river valley
we have had situations come up because
for example the the college made the
decision that they're going to do their
covet testing on friday afternoons
that's perfectly reasonable for them
it's not reasonable for the community
college nursing students
because they work and so their ability
to attend classes was affected
because if you have to be at work friday
at noon time and you can't have the test
that needs
to allow you to be on campus how do you
do that
now the situation's been worked out and
again i
raise it not criticizing but pointing
out
that there are distinct needs between
what community college students are
people who elect
to begin at a community college versus a
four-year
i would also go on to talk a little bit
more about
transfer
so many of the stories that you hear
about
i'll call them transfer disasters
are in fact not transfer disasters so
we often hear the story of now as the
student took a math class
and it was adequate for the associate
degree and then when that individual
transferred to a four-year program that
math course wasn't counted or if it was
counted it was
kind of meaningless elective credit
meaning that this individual
when he or she completed their
bachelor's degree was going to graduate
with 140
or 150 credits
it's it was entirely appropriate in my
example
for the four-year college to say that's
not the right math course
if somebody starts off in liberal arts
and decides that they want to
go into engineering that math class
which
may be affectionately described as math
for poets
is not the right math course and so for
the university system
to not accept it in that way is
perfectly reasonable
but it's a complicated explanation
now there's been work done and i will
specifically cite
the work that was done between the
university of new hampshire and the
community college system
sponsored by the mellon foundation which
has resulted in 22
strong articulation agreements and the
way that
those articulations came about
was the work of a particular professor
from the community college system with
the university
leslie barber leslie then once she
understood what the particular course
or degree was at the university system
organized the community college system
and now no matter which of the community
college system
uh no matter which community college
you're at if you follow the prescribed
pathway
your entry to the university system is
assured
it's one way we can do business there
are other ways that we can do
business with all of our four-year
partners
i'm going to talk also about i.t systems
we um i mentioned uh that we are using
banner
the community pardon me the university
system is using several different
uh programs
there's going to have to be a lot of
work over time putting all of those
together so again what is the plan
how do we go forward uh representative
moffat
brought up that the community college
faculty and staff are members of the new
hampshire
retirement system we wouldn't describe
ourselves now representative moffat as
state employees
but we're certainly tied to some of the
state
systems those will have to be worked out
we have at least 11 unions
among the group of us what's going to
happen there
and i will say that this is a great
concern
on the part of our uh faculty and staff
at this moment uh risk management
uh we have so many areas an intellectual
property
what what we do in that area what the
university system
does very different because how our
faculty
are identified and treated is is very
different in the systems
you know debt and reserves
and marketing and fundraising
all of these things will have to be
figured out
um and i do hope that as our legislature
looking at what happens to benefit our
residents that you will think in terms
of
what you can do to preserve the missions
of the two entities
i appreciated what dr burke said about
the regional needs
that is the key here because
the one thing i've learned living in new
hampshire is that our regions are quite
distinctive
and right now the community colleges are
present
but what can you do to preserve the
regional
needs so that we are addressing the
uh needs of not only business but also
of our residents
so i will stop there and um and
let you uh go forward with questions
but i wanted to point out to you several
of the areas
that i wanted uh you to take into
consideration as you look at
what is the best way to bring the
systems together
i think bringing the systems together
makes sense
but how it is you do that and and what
it is you think about
is very important to thank you thank you
very much
uh dr heward are there questions for the
community college system
yes representative thanks thanks very
much uh
mr chair um excuse me and thanks
thanks uh susan for uh joining us um
this morning
um you know in in in
in my experience in in private industry
spent a lot of time i've spent a lot of
time writing business plans
and um and i was wondering if if you're
aware of any examples
of um of cis you know system
um you know in in considering systems
merging
if um if if states have taken it upon
uh to to essentially start with a
business plan
type of type of approach on that and um
and are there any examples where after
the business plan was developed and it
may have taken
uh quite a while to develop such plans
that after the plan was was written it
was sort of determined that um that
maybe
it um you know it doesn't move forward
i'm not aware of that happening i think
that many states
find themselves in the in the situation
that we're in as we look at declining
high school enrollments and what the
potential impact could be
i guess what i would say is the the
plans that have led to effective
reorganizations have primarily been
between smaller entities and and and
i'll
uh talk about the university of maine
and the work that they're doing
they've been moving towards uh
unifying into one uh accreditation if
you will
for a number of years but they've done
it
uh you know one uh
college site like machias to a
another uh one of their locations
um so to me the the best examples are
places
where we've had entities unite
um one college to one college or several
colleges
together rather than uh starting
uh to put the systems together like i
look at
wisconsin uh which brought a number of
its systems together and is now in the
process
of trying to figure out how to um sort
of
straighten out things that were that
happened
unexpectedly from the merger uh
that they need to look at minnesota is
another example
i spoke to the gentleman who was the
speaker of the house and the
head of the minnesota system and and
they talked about the fact that it's
taken
quite a number of years to recognize the
regional value of the community colleges
and to go back to that so i'm not aware
of um a plan being put in place
uh and then people looking at it and
saying nope we
we shouldn't go forward and and do this
uh and
and i think it's probably um how
urgent folks thought the situation was
but i'm keenly aware
of the negative impact on community
colleges when this goes forward
too quickly um and the the things that
make
community colleges community colleges
are lost
great thank you susan thank you thank
you very much uh susan i i got one
comment here
uh you recently through the community
college i had a report
put together by the national center for
higher education management systems and
one of the
cases they looked at was connecticut and
you've indicated
earlier here that you have had
familiarity with that system down there
did they have when they went into a
merger process
was there any uh time frames
which you you see them transitioning and
moving forward
similar to what vermont did with their
bridge year
is what are we looking at in terms of
time frame for the community college
system
in connecticut or in vermont well
i'm not really familiar with connecticut
i'm somewhat familiar with what happened
over with linden
and all those over in vermont with the
bridge year
was there any support in other words did
they plan on doing this all in one year
or was it
phased in by elements okay
um in connecticut the original plan was
like a five-year plan and they've
obviously
tremendously exceeded that there was a
plan to look at the community colleges
first and to make
decisions about them and then to move on
to the csus the connecticut state
universities
um but that again they're far outside of
their plan
um connecticut is a
the connecticut system is a heavily
unionized
uh system um there's an organization
called
cbac which is the state employees
bargaining
coalition and so
um i would say that
uh because the plan didn't begin with
conversations with all of the
um stakeholders that
uh they ended up with a significant
um opposition which continues
to this day uh and so
again as a plan is being formulated i
would
you know suggest that the various
stakeholders
be included in the planning process
there was an attempt
at one point to do that but because the
plan had been set forward as you know
this is going to be our timeline
this is what we're going to accomplish
wasn't able
to be accomplished because the
opposition rose up fiercely
and early thank you very much
i i think one last from representative
miller and then we're going to move into
uh catherine provincial and joe moran
go ahead bro are you you gotta unmute
yourself now
uh thank you rick uh susan one of the
things that that's become
clear in the people that we've been
talking with is is a concern of the
timing
of um trying to put this together the
governor made the
announcement at the budget meaning
there's some questions about whether
that's the appropriate procedure to do
it through the budget
an outside person the point is we've
been hearing from people to say that's
going to take
time the dilemma that we have right now
is that both systems
are looking for a chancellor and so
this this uh uncertainty of where we are
uh comes into that conversation and i'm
going to ask the same question
of of the university system
if we sure decide to go ahead with the
system
could each of these systems place their
search
on hold until we figure out exactly
where we're going to go with this
because it would seem to me it's going
to be difficult to
hire somebody into a chancellor position
with the unknown factor of exactly where
we are going with this so
the question to you susan is would the
uh
would the ccsnh system
uh if we're going to go forward with
this plan put their search
on hold now i know that puts you in a
compromising position because of july
you're supposed to be retired again
but from just from a theoretical
standpoint
is that something that that you think
that the system would
place on hold yeah i actually don't have
to be theoretical about this
representative miler we had a a meeting
uh yesterday of our board
and we're going ahead with our
chancellor's search and offering the
two-year
contract because in reading the language
as it exists in the bill
um the new entity the new system would
be created july
2023 um we had as you know
begun a search for a chancellor in the
fall
and um we have approximately 70
applications we're working with a search
firm
and so what our initial thought was was
that we would
have to continue with an interim
chancellor because
the way that we're organized as a is as
a system
and we need a ceo given how our
again our system operates we
were going to cancel the search and we
talked with the principal of the search
firm and he said
people are not frightened by this we've
been keeping them informed
all the way through about what the
status
of the system is and in fact there are
quite a number of people uh who are
applicants
who see this as an exciting opportunity
and that
a two-year window to work on the
creation of this
or the you know whatever is going to
happen
is not daunting so yesterday our
board voted and we've let the governor's
office know
on going forward with our search and
bringing somebody in this summer
to be the chancellor with the clear
understanding
that this is a two-year contract and we
are not making any promises
about anything going forward
thank you very much that's that's very
clear uh joe i see you just put your
hand up
i just wanted to respond to this
particular question
you know if you if you if you
place yourselves in in the seed of the
future board
as it's going through this transitional
especially it would be enormously
helpful for that board
if ccsnh had a chancellor um
and if unfortunately it isn't going to
be susan having somebody
in place will make the what's going to
be a very challenging task
more manageable than if immediately
the new board is going to have to have
seven
ccs and h institutions and four usna
institutions reporting in so
i think there's a lot of wisdom in what
what susan is describing the
the ccs imaging board has decided on
thank you i should clarify what i said i
had said the board it's the executive
committee
uh who has made this decision
well thank you very much dr heward uh
with that i think we're going to
transition now and i don't know
uh protocol here whether i introduce the
chancellor first or
the chair of the trustees uh
organizational structure here
uh uh i'll make i'll make it easy for
you representative vlad you go with the
board chair first
go for it joe okay thank you
um i'll i'll
we're going to run through some slides
and as i understand our
charge it is to try to give you a very
specific sense
of why we feel our board feels so much
urgency
about about the
challenges facing higher ed and why we
very quickly and unanimously
voted in support of the governor's
proposal let me just give you a word
about background from
my own background i was ceo of albany
international for 12 years i was
responsible for bringing
the company as a public company bringing
the company's headquarters
here to new hampshire and uh
starting up that big operation in
rochester the big aerospace operation
before that i was president of bentley
university and before that
dean and a professor of business
strategy at rpi and prior to that i
spent my year starting part of a career
in ge and working in
president reagan science a president
reagan science advisor
i've so i've spent my whole career
really bouncing back and forth between
business and university and always
working that interface and so
the reason i joined the board was
because when i was
trying to get that plant in rochester
started up and we needed to recruit 500
people
i spent my team like my entire life
struggling with the problem of
finding enough talent to get this thing
going
here in new hampshire spent a lot of
time working with great bay we set up a
training program
for associates who would be ready for
the factory floor spent a lot of time
with unh working on trying to find
engineers and scientists for r d
um we spent a ton of time trying to find
bachelors and masters of industrial
engineering who could
play the supervisory role in laying out
and leading those plants and
they were great partners and but by and
large
we had to go outside for a ton of the
new talent because it just wasn't
available within state
and it cost us a lot uh we actually
decided in the end
not to bring over our finance and
accounting group was 50 really good pay
really good paying jobs that we left
back in albany because it just wasn't
the talent available here
and it wasn't because uh public higher
ed wasn't a great talent
a great partner both a and unh it's just
the talent wasn't there wasn't enough of
it
and so when the governor gave me the
opportunity to join the board i jumped
at it because i thought here was a
chance to
from the inside actively work the
problem of trying to promote
the pathways between public higher ed
and states employers
who are trying to create the kinds of
new jobs that really make a difference
in the state higher value jobs
um and so if i sound a little passionate
what i'm about to tell you
it's because of that experience um
the punchline uh of what i'm about to
say is this
higher ed's is facing an existential
threat
uh and that threat is accelerating we're
just at the front end of it and it's
already
daunting um we are out of time as
dr burks described earlier
if we had started this five years ago
which is when
ross cattell started warning us about
what was coming
if we had started then to plan uh
we'd be in much better shape right now
but that time is done we're
we're out of time and you'll see that as
you look at the numbers
particularly as you look at the
financials
there is a ton of planning that's
required a ton
and i think um i think susan gave you a
great sense
of just the long list of challenges that
are going to have to be navigated to try
to do this right but the question is not
should there be planning but rather who
should be doing
planning and what in in my experience
across
multiple sectors from what i've seen in
other states in higher ed
when it works best and i think don
mentioned this with pennsylvania when it
works best the people doing the planning
are the people responsible for the
managing and the implementation
uh it's you you got to think about this
as taking a 30-foot sailboat and trying
to chart your way from hope from
honolulu to san francisco
through a series of monsoons and yes you
got to have the long-term plan
but you got to manage your way through
the monsoons or you never get there
and you're constantly adjusting your
short-term plans
because of the because of the monsoon
and adjusting the long-term plan
because of how you had to deal with the
monsoon the short term
so having the right board in place
that then has the task that hires the
right ceo
and that then has the task of charting
through both short term and
long term is the right way to get on
with this
particularly if you're in crisis and
we're in crisis
and so that's why and we have an acute
sense of it
on our board and that's why we came out
so quickly
and forcefully in favor of
the governor's proposal to put together
a board
representative of the two systems get
them to hire a ceo and then get on with
this task and as he in his words
and if you don't you're going to get
crushed i think that's also why the
four commissioners serving on the two
boards just forcefully
endorsed the governor's plan same reason
there's a sense of you know
our hair is on fire we gotta get on with
this too late to talk
so that's the that's the punch line let
me let me back up here a bit and
um kathy and i are just gonna walk you
through some slides that give you some
concrete data and it's the same data
we're looking at support
and and honestly every other good board
and leadership
system leadership group in the country
is is looking at at the same time
struggling with so the starting point
for this whole conversation
is the demographic challenge facing
higher ed
and if you look at the upper left-hand
curve
look at the purple line which is the
bottom line that's
northeast united states that's the pool
of
college age higher ed age
students or people available
or higher ed over the next
25 years over the next 20 years and you
can see
that that purple line is us and so
there's been a dip
and this is all calibrated to 2018. so
2018 is 100
so you can see there's a drop of right
away from 2018 to 2020 then there's a
little bit of breathing space and then
whoa the thing drops up through the
floor
and never recovers that's 100
predictable because it's just based on
the number of people who have been born
there's no uncertainty about that now
um just a few points to highlight here
first ired has been
in growth mode since the gi bill
uh immediately after world war ii with a
couple of blips along the way
it has always been growing because
through the baby boom uh and beyond
the the number of people going to
college had always been growing
this is unprecedented it hasn't happened
ever
and the scale involved here is very hard
for people to get their heads around
you need to be thinking textile industry
in new hampshire or paper industry you
know decades ago
or think bricks and mortar retailing
today
it's that kind of a magnitude of a
change and higher ed is not ready for it
because
everybody who's grown up in higher ed
has been thinking grow grow grow
second point and this is one people in
higher don't talk about
there is a food chain in higher ed
there are the elite schools and the even
if you saw an article today in wall
street journal
uh elite schools are being buried with
applications right
beneath the elite schools they're the
schools ranked 50th to 100
then there are the regional colleges the
usnh institutions that are ranked below
the hundredth
and then the two-year schools the elites
and the 50-100 are going to be fined
through this they're facing the same
demographics
but all they need to do is if they're
having trouble filling their class
they just cherry-picked down from
students who in the past from
from to schools pulling away students
who in the past wouldn't have gotten
into the elite
so if mit and harvard have a problem
which they won't they'll just
they'll just cherry pick from tufts in
bc
and tufts and bc have a problem they're
just going to cherry pick
you northeastern and umass amherst
and umass lowell and if those have a
problem
they're just going to turn around and
cherry-pick unh
and maine and if unh and maine have a
problem they're going to carry picane
and plymouth and keene plymouth have a
problem they're going to cherry-pick
an hti in manchester and the data says
it's already happening so the farther
down the
food chain you are and public higher in
new hampshire is farther down the food
chain
the harder the impact this demographic
is going to have
now you can see on the lower right hand
side
the two-year institutions across the
country
but and especially in the northeast are
getting hit
even harder there isn't quite that flat
curve
through the first half of this decade
and it drops hard
same trend we're seeing it across the
country uh
we're seeing it in today's application
trends both in state and across the
northeast
you should hear some of the stories from
suny now
uh if you go one more slide kathy
new hampshire is being hit especially
hard
and i i thought this i thought you this
was particularly interesting
these are slides from the
audited financial statements of ccsnh in
2018.
and this is you know this is what ross
was telling us back then and we weren't
listening hard enough
you know what he what he was arguing and
it's in the
uh the 2018 auditor financial statement
what he said is look there are three
drivers
of enrollment um or
for ccsnh and he could have said for
usnh as well
um it's employment it's
you know if the employment rate is very
high we have more trouble recruiting
number two is the number of students
graduating from new hampshire high
schools
and number three is competition from
other institutions so think
and that process is just subscribing
so here is in 2018 the forecast
for the decline in the number of high
school graduates in new hampshire
between 2018 and 2032
it's completely consistent with the
demographic chart i just showed you
the the bad news here is new hampshire
is getting hit even harder than the rest
of
than the rest of new england as you can
see on the right hand side he was he was
predicting basically a 26
decline in the number of high school
graduates
who would that would be available for
all of us in public higher ed to recruit
over the next 15 years now the data in
2020 that just came out from the
chronicle
what it'll tell you is looking out just
10 years
the states that the state that is going
to have it toughest
is connecticut it's going to be down 17
percent number of high school graduates
over the next 10 years
number two in the country new hampshire
with a 15
line uh maine is at 10 percent
massachusetts is an 8 percent decline
vermont is seven percent decline we are
getting
clobbered there's no hiding from it
this is like gravity
now i wish i could tell you that that
was the entirety of the problem
it's only half the problem kathy
if you look inside the shrinking pool of
available students
what you learn what you see and the
data's overwhelming here is it's a
it's a much poorer pool and a pool
of shrinking pool of people who need
greater financial aid
and that's because of the demographic
composition there are
the the number of minority families that
higher ed is serving grows from about
uh 29 of the total in
uh 2000 to 45 percent by 2018
it's even higher now the number of
immigrant families first generation
immigrant families that higher ed
is serving was something like 20 percent
of the total population
in 2000 it's 28 of the total population
in 2018 and that continues to grow too
so
the net result is as the number of
students therefore the amount of tuition
is steadily declining
with gravity demographic gravity
the amount of financial aid that we have
to pay to that shrinking pool
is growing so here you can see this is
just over a short period of time
the growth of financial aid that usnh
has paid as a result of this change in
the population
so you get a double whammy here net
revenue
net tuition revenue is being hit both
by this waterfall of shrinking high
school graduates
and by the need for increasing financial
aid
to support those students so if you go
to the next curve next slide
joe if i could just make one more point
we
um project that that blue line is going
to continue to increase but to joe's
point
remember there's more aid being
distributed
to fewer students because the the head
count
is on the decline but the aid is on the
increase
you'll see that in a minute in the next
right there yeah and and
you know the point you just can't
emphasize enough we're barely at the
front end of this
that cliff hits in 2025 2026
and it's a multi-year clip so if you
look on the left hand side of the curve
slide here this is just uh the the top
curve the blue curve is usnh's
net tuition rev uh is
net tuition revenue so
you know leave aside room and board
leave aside contracts and grants
and so you can see that net revenue at
the
front end of this crisis
is already shrinking by about eight
percent
and close to you know 28 million dollars
in a very short period of time now
the next curve is the red curve is
state appropriation and you can see that
while
our net revenue has come down by by
about 28 million
state appropriations have held steady
but then have happily increased a little
bit but you can see not
nearly enough to offset
the impact of the demographic of the
clients
now the the net result
is the gray bars we're seeing rapidly
shrinking margins you know when i first
started on the board we used to
we used to be accustomed to three
percent operating margins
uh because of this decline even as we're
holding the line on cost
uh you can see our margins begin to slip
from one and a half percent to
point seven percent this year uh fiscal
year twenty one
if you exclude the effect of covet so
um we're looking at a negative two
percent now
we've got a major restructuring plan to
try to get get us back to break even by
next year but
keep in mind these trends continue so
you know we project out for 2022 and 23
further declines in net revenue kathy
what are we
what are we expecting in 22 and 23s
probably
in total operating revenue we're looking
at a nine percent decline
from 20 from 20 to 23. nine
nine percent decline in operating
revenue and again
this is just gravity there's no there's
none
it's not you can't pretend it's not
happening because it's happening
and that still leaves us well before we
hit that demographic cliff
now you know we don't have as much
access to as much data
over on the ccs and h side but if you
look at the published data
in the audited financials you see
exactly the same trend
so net tuition revenue the blue line
very short period of
time shrinks from 47.9 million dollars
to 39 million and uh
fy 21 the the audited fy 20 audited
statement said enrollment for fy21 is
down another 11 percent
happily for the state for the well-being
of the state
the legislature stepped up and has
dramatically increased
support for ccsnh going from 43.8
million appropriations
to 57 million appropriations so in that
case
the state has been able to offset the
sharp decline uh due to demographics
but remember we're at the front end of
this so that increase in state
appropriation is going to have to
continue at pretty much that pace
uh in order to offset this um
tsunami that we're all being hit with
now just just i just want to make a few
more points
um if you go to the next slide
uh where we're as a state
heading into this storm in a position of
disadvantage
we're we're in about as weak a position
as a state
as there is in the country so you know
you start by saying
by looking at the number of high school
graduates from this state that leave the
state
to go to school and you know from an
employer's perspective once they leave
it's that much harder and that much more
expensive to get them back so
you look at students high school
students leaving
to to enroll in schools outside of
new hampshire it's it's almost 60
percent
of our high school graduates and don't
forget ross's chart
we're talking about a rapidly shrinking
pool of high school graduates
and if we continue to lose at that rate
this is going to get very hard even when
you
even when you include two two years so
students enrolling both in two and four
year
we're still the number two exporter of
high school students
uh second point another
uh background point if uh kathy if you
move to the next slide
we're entering into this crisis as
um as the second most expensive
public higher education institute for
in-state tuition in the country
so the right way to look at this curve
is the blue lines this is for four-year
tuition for your schools
the blue line blue bars represent
in-state tuition the orange bars
represent out-of-state tuition so you
add them together to get
total tuition but what i want to draw
your attention to is the blue curve so
this eye chart here new hampshire is is
the second from the right so we're the
second
most expensive tuition
for public higher education in the
country
now if you go next slides
same is true for our two years so what
this is telling you
is not just part of the explanation why
so many of
our high school students are leaving but
there is no way
that public higher ed in this state can
address this revenue crisis by
increasing tuition
this is no way so
um and if we tried
the market will just throw it right back
at us because of the competitive factors
so we have to find a way of offsetting
this
rapidly shrinking net tuition revenue
with at best holding tuition flat now in
truth
we ought to be cutting tuition precisely
because
it's so expensive and if we if we're
serious about reversing the trend of the
loss of high school students we better
start
by lowering tuition and making the
public higher ed in the state more
affordable
it's going to be very very hard to do
that at a time when our net revenue is
is crashing on us now on the other hand
if you were one of the schools off on
the left hand side of the curve
you can see or even in the middle of the
curve you can see you've got room there
to maybe
uh increase tuition some and have
students bear more of the cost
as as the revenue crisis hits but
there's just no way
we have the ability to do that
uh last slide or last background slide
um another reason that we're entering
into this
crisis in a position of disadvantage is
we are overbuilt
relatively overbuilt for public higher
education
so this this chart just simply
calculates
the the ratio of population
to number of institutions in higher
education
so utah has and if you look at the right
hand column
that's the population of people under
25. so utah has
the largest population being served by
the smallest number of institutions
we're 45 first on that curve so we have
for a relatively small
numerator population a relatively large
denominator
number of institutions 11 that are
serving public higher education and you
can look at the
states that are rated lower than us they
tend to have a lot of
dispersed geographical requirements so
so we're um we're exporting more than
anybody
we're more expensive than just about
everybody except for vermont
and and we're starting in an overbuilt
position that's not a great place to be
to address
to address what's going to be a really
profound
uh generational uh revenue crisis in
higher education
now um kathy you go to the next slide um
all of this i know you know this all of
this is dramatically exacerbated and
probably
accelerating by accelerated by the
pandemic
so what the pandemic is doing is
is creating smaller enrollments of
incoming students
it's creating weaker retention of
existing students
and it means because we've spread out
our campuses fewer students
utilizing campus room and board which is
another
source of revenue and therefore loss of
revenue at the same time because of the
economic impact particularly on the
lowest
the the poorest segments of society
which is what public higher education in
general
and two years in particular that's their
mission to serve
they're the ones that are hardest hit by
by this those students that who years
and public higher ed are facing
serving they're the ones that are
hardest hit by this
by this pandemic and then of course
institutions are
having to take on much higher costs some
of them offset by the government
that's because of trying to preserve
safety but what's the short-term impact
well for us nh the short-term impact for
us
is 136 million dollars of code-related
losses
offset by about 61 million of stimulus
and gopher
we'll get through it and we think we get
by careful cash management we think we
can get through without having to
liquidate any of our endowment to cover
losses
but there's a long-term impact on this
as well and the long-term impact is
we're depleting our cash reserves
if you were to get through this day's
cash on hand than we did before
the smaller classes during the pandemic
you know they become sophomores and
juniors and seniors and as
as their upperclassmen counterparts
graduate we're left with a fundamentally
strong
smaller pool of students that we're
serving
the loss of family income during the
pandemic it takes time as we learned in
2008-2009
to rebuild that that income and that
means
more need for financial aid than we
otherwise would have had
and so our fear is what happens here
is the pandemic at least for us nh
probably wipes out
that flat period of the demographic
curve where we were telling ourselves
would have some breathing space for a
few years before
having to take on that demographic cliff
and that joe and that's that's why
last spring you know we had been
planning for this
that the headwinds coming but last
spring it took on a new sense of urgency
and this wholesale restructuring
project to take 10 out of our cost
structure by 2023
was absolutely necessary and we have
that roadmap we're on that the
the other uh follow up to joe's point
where we're
um we're looking at probably a hundred
million dollars of our cash
being depleted over the course of the
pandemic we've had to pull back on all
capital spending and we had built up
reserves we
we pretty much take care of our own
capital needs
and um that will be effectively wiped
out
by the time we're to 2023. for good
reason for good reason but it's just the
the reality of where we are right now so
let less
uh less slides um which is
the next which really gets to what
kathy's just saying because
of the long-term structural trends
um and the looming pandemic we launched
a
significant restructuring plan that
called for taking out ten percent of
costs
on our campuses and the goal really was
to very overtly offset
both the combination of these
demographic trends and the pandemic we
were willing to
suffer through significant losses during
the pandemic
in order to keep our people safe but we
had to
do during the pandemic whatever it was
going to take
to get us back to break even by 22 and
get us a small margin by 23.
and so that that so we are right in the
middle of a major restructuring program
which the basic approach is we're
rolling back our expenses to fiscal year
we're restructuring our benefits we're
consolidating doing a major
consolidation of our back
back office administrative functions
there's significant rebalancing going on
of our academic programs on each of the
campuses
there are at least 500
roughly 500 faculty and staff who are
through a voluntary separation
retirement program who are leaving who
are choosing to retire
unfortunately there will be some
involuntary separations as well
but we're talking a radical
restructuring
it and uh which for us and for
most other institutions is unprecedented
in scope
scale on schedule you're not hearing
much about it which just gives you a
sense
of uh a shared
understanding of the urgency that higher
ed is facing over the
across our system in campuses you know
you think about
think about all of the visibility there
was two years three years ago when unh
try to um
try to reduce its workforce by 15
lecturers in
in modern languages and and the heat
that ccsnh took
by by making up taking a very necessary
step of reducing 10 of their people
we're we're talking north of 500 people
and it so far on schedule
and most of those people are leaving
voluntarily because of a package were
put together for them
that's the good news the bad news if we
do everything right
and we get lucky with this year's
incoming class
i'm not sure we will get lucky this only
catches us up to those trends
this doesn't this doesn't get us ahead
catches us up
it's taking out 70 million dollars just
to catch up to the decline in net
revenues that were
that that are pretty much locked in uh
already
and so the hard work is ahead of us
and now we know our brethren
at ccsnh are going through the same
thing but it'll be worse for them
just because of all of the things i've
talked about
and so as we look at that as a board
that's why
we say look we can we we can do
everything possible to optimize within
the boundaries of usnh
but if we take our you know if we put on
our hats as fiduciaries for state
clearly there are many more ways that
you can
move to optimally serve the citizens of
the state if you take
both systems together and try to and try
to optimize
as one unified system and don gave you
an example of how there's so much more
that
white mountain and and plymouth could be
doing if we didn't have the governance
barriers that we do
now it's not going to be easy it's going
to be
very difficult but and it's going to be
doing it through crisis constantly
but that's why we say start with a
unified board
start with a ceo-type chancellor
get everyone understanding the scale of
the problem
and then let's work together to navigate
through the many many legitimate issues
and questions that
that susan and don laid out there is
something very significant the
legislature can do
to help public higher ed get to a
sustainable place as i tell you right
now
we i'll speak for myself i don't believe
right now new public higher education in
new hampshire
is on a path to sustainable to a
sustainable future to a financially
viable future
i think it's on a path to a to a cliff
the best thing that the legislature
could do to support public higher
education
during this crisis is to give public
higher ed
a cushion to give
this new board time to work through the
many issues
that it's going to have to address if on
day one
they're going to have to be dealing with
budget cuts
at the same time that they're going to
have to navigate through the
hangover of the pandemic and the
continuing demographic trends
this is going to be really tough so
i'll stop there well i
i'll just add not not just the budget
cuts
uh the community college system and
university system put a
joint fiscal note together for this
section of house bill 2 that
that this board is going to need
some external support and the resources
to bring in some external support to
really think through
representative luna the business plan
the workflows the strategic vision the
timeline
um so i wholeheartedly agree with
with the joe's statement we've mentioned
this to division two
and to the governor's office that now is
not the time to cut the appropriation
when this hard work is ahead
and there's there's going to need to be
some investment dollars
to to support the board
i guess we can stop sharing yeah
okay thank you very much uh joe and
catherine
representative i've i've provided this
um
slide deck to jennifer to jen right so
she can provide it
uh to the committee members yeah jen
would you
please email that out to all committee
members absolutely
thank you um are there questions for
dr moran and uh catherine provencher
i can remember joe that my father used
to work for globe
albany and that's not the same as albany
international is it
it's not no i think we talked about that
once yeah
yeah uh
let's go on rep representative moffat do
you have a question
uh yeah sure real quick for any of the
uh panelists uh the president
uh and others who campaigned for
president uh i'm looking at some of the
recent uh news items uh the president
campaigned on a pla he has a plan to
make community college
and four-year public colleges uh free
tuition for them
so uh he's new
his administration is no but in terms of
the president's plan
to uh make tuition free for for your
organizations uh is there anything that
you see flowing from this that would
be helpful
susan you want me to take that or you
want to take that well you could start
and then i'll chime in
okay uh i i think we
we find it pretty scary uh the the
prospect here
is i mean this has to be thought through
very carefully if um
if you have an increase in students
without
the resources to support them
it it becomes the worst of unfunded
mandates
um if if um
because they're not paying tuition but
you've got to support them
um if uh the
the reimbursement for the students
is linked to the national averages
we're gonna get slammed so in other
words if
if there's a i mean the goal is really
worthy don't get me wrong i mean you
want to get to
65 by 25 this is the way to do it and
you know my
the first instinct is to stand up and
cheer
but you've got to look at the details
because it could really get us in
trouble
let's take for example this again we're
uniquely
ill positioned for this because of our
high cost of tuition
so what's there's no way they're going
to reward
less efficient institutions by saying
well you know
new hampshire you charge 17 000 a year
you're going to be reimbursed 17 000 a
year for the students that were letting
in
it's going to be well the national
average is 5000 maybe we'll make a
regional adjustment
that's what you're going to get for each
student so
um it doesn't solve the demographic
problem
it may make our our mismatch between
revenue and costs a lot worse than it
is if it's not really careful
yeah and i would comment that
the free tuition uh plays out in
different ways in different states
whether we're talking about the
kentucky promise so the the tennessee
program and so on
um oftentimes that program is aimed at
full-time students who are recent high
school graduates
that's not the population of our
community colleges
our uh 70 something percent of our
population
is 22 24
or older our average age is about 27. so
the question for me
would be how this is going to play out
i would say right now i'm more
interested in the proposal to double
the pell allotment
that that would continue to serve all of
our students because if you're a
part-time student
your allotment would be adjusted but it
would still pay more
than is currently being paid you know
one of the issues that our students
might have if they were free tuition it
was a surprise to me but if you want to
go into automotive
for example you have to buy your own
tools that's about two thousand dollars
and um we're fortunate to have the
medallion fund
uh under the charitable foundation and
many students
benefit that way but it it is an answer
of sorts and of course
dr jill biden has been in community
colleges
uh forever and so she really does
understand the issue it would be great
to have the help um you know
one of the slides that you saw before uh
was produced by
roscatel looking at the number of
the declining number of high school
grads he used that slide with our board
to make the point that there are about
000 people in this state who have some
degree of college credit
we should be doing more to go after and
serve that population
than we've been doing and while i don't
dispute the figures
i do see a different path forward for
community colleges
once we come through the pandemic
nationally
nobody expected community colleges just
to suffer in the way that we have we are
absolutely on the average
and it really is because our students
are either essential workers whether
they're lnas or they're in retail
um or their parents and they haven't
been able to uh balance things
the challenge for us at this moment
is to help them figure out how they can
come back so long answer
i i do hope for more money to be coming
i'm looking forward for instance
to another round of tax grants to
support our students
uh we are and always have been lean
but we are not fragile we find ways to
deal
with what we have as a situation in
front of us
i i just one little point here um
i just read an article that 25 percent
of colleges are going to be out of
business here in the next few years
um but i'm looking at some figures i can
remember talking with roscatel
and here's another article i've just
read
between 2001 and 2021
tuition tuition for colleges rose 140
percent
yet we still continue to have only about
62 percent
of our folks that are attending college
graduating in six years
so that's causing a real whammy in terms
of the cost of education for these kids
is there anything we're doing to
increase the
the number our our percentage for kids
that can
graduate in six years from the 62
percent level and this is a national
level
so i don't know exactly what it may be
for
for the university of new hampshire or
keene or plymouth
can somebody help me out net rep
representative vlad
we have the highest graduation rate
the new hampshire public four years do
than than any other state in new england
we publish a dashboard i can get that to
to jen it has a
number of different metrics but um
we're well above the national average
here in new hampshire publix for
for that six year graduation rate but
has our tuition rate also increased at
that 140 percent over the last year
it depends on the time frame uh
representative ladd if you
you know if you look through
the time that uh the good old days
you know when when um you just heard
from
uh ed mckay during ed mckay's time
you just read a letter from uh former
trustees who used to be on the board
back in those days yeah you'd see
you'd see increases three four five
percent
and then when the state cut its
allocation dramatically there were some
big increases
in tuition with we've fought hard to
hold a line on tuition
for the very reason you described for i
think the last four years and in our
current budget proposal we said we would
actually drop tuition if we get an
increase in state support
inspiring christopher to drop tuition
but i know ccs has done a great job
holding the line on tuition
the the we're still too high and
so part of the crisis here is we've got
to find a way of lowering the cost
dependence
and tough to do when you're you know
your revenue is shrinking so fast but
that's what the goal needs to be
um as for the second part of your
question um
what are we doing to improve graduation
rate you know the
i i want to defer to susan and don don's
got a lot to say on this subject
and i know susan does too so i'll stop
thank you thank you uh i
i don't know if we have to have that
answered at this moment but that that
would be a concern i would like to
offer the opportunity to others on the
committee to ask questions at
representative uh luna thanks very much
rick
and um and thanks catherine and and joe
for joining us
uh this morning so um you know i'm
i've had the uh the the honor to to
serve on
on boards both at uh uh unh
engineering technology program and uh
the nhti advisory board
and um one of the things that came up at
a
recent advisory board meeting back in
february was when uh president mullen
zavisky
discussed the nhti strategic plan
and she laid out four specific
points to it the first one was retention
the second one was workforce development
the third was effectiveness and
sustainability and the fourth was
diversity equity and inclusion
but i wanted to poke specifically on the
workforce development one because
one of the one of the findings uh they
had and that they that they built into
their plan
was uh reflected the fact that 65 of
their students want credentials
as opposed to um necessarily two-year
degrees or four-year degrees
and and so that that pivot um
being something that the community
colleges can
can address on rapidly short order i
think is a very
um a very good um a good opportunity
for our for our community colleges i was
wondering
you know given the given the the um
precipitous decline
in in high school uh
graduates uh projected over the next few
years
what are you what is the university
system seeing in terms of
what you're structuring plan and
everything but what do your students
want
well um
they're it's like you know that's a deep
question and there's so many layers to
it and again i'll
um defer to don for part of the answer
but the
the starting point for us is 80 of
the population that higher education in
this country is serving
and that number is going to grow our
non-traditional students
and uh so you know the kind of students
that in the past
would uh normally have been the province
of
community colleges have become the
province of all of higher ed
and the you know the emergence of
distance learning
as a dominant modality um
makes that makes the concept of
education as a lifelong process um
being
[Music]
being attained through a
longer periods of time in chunks
only some of those some of which
are traditional diplomas has become
um sort of the common expectation
[Music]
uh across higher education and so
um you know if you look at unh
it it's putting a lot of emphasis and
look at where its growth is it's in
professional
post-baccalaureate programs
and it's going in some cases in
traditional format and
both physically and in degree in some
cases far less
traditional uh both in format
and in in whether it's a credential or
even a certificate
even something less than financial a
badge
i just got off a zoom call with a major
a very well known i won't mention the
name
private institution in boston
and we were doing a brainstorming
session on precisely that question
is how how do they take advantage of
their reputation
in a particular field where they're
really strong
and use it to do everything from
host baccalaureate um summer programs
to credentials to badges to lifelong
uh coming back and forth every once in a
while to distance degrees
uh spread out over a period of time to
distance
one-year programs it's become the norm
to work through i would say that
we in new hampshire are late
but you can't you can't expect to
navigate through
them through the changes without
without getting there
this is an example where under one
governance structure
we may be able to facilitate rather than
compete
so we should if if the community college
system is really good
at credentialing a certain population
of granite staters university system
should not be competing and and vice
versa
let's give a quick example of what we've
done in the last year
actually the last six months is start a
cyber securities
credential and also credential
in innovation and entrepreneurship which
gives a student
all the background experience they need
whatever their
area of interest is in business that
gives them the capability to really run
the business
so those are two that we just did
you know but part of the why that
question is so deep
is um it's a totally different business
model and the revenue
that you expect from you know if you're
thinking again about this revenue crisis
and how you manage institutions
um you get far less revenue from those
kind of programs
than you did by having 18 to 20 year
olds
crowded together in a physical location
aim for room and board
and um so that's part of the reason this
is such a
tsunami that you've got to navigate your
way through is
you can get to that other population but
you've got to do it in a way
that preserves that maintains the
financial viability of your institutions
that's
that's the hard part right right no i
i appreciate that very much joe and and
and certainly
you know the differences between the
university systems
university system colleges and the
community colleges i mean you just
mentioned room and board
um you know i think nhti you know that's
where my familiarity is
has a has a pretty lively um um
uh you know and and robust um
um dining services and number you know
students on campus
you know i think they have a small
number of
students that live on campus i think
they're an outlier in the uh
most of the community colleges are not
residential institutions
but um but uh but they do um
uh you know have the ability to uh to
make up revenue through volume
yeah over there
so so um so you know so that's a
you know so i i think that's a that's an
area that
that the community colleges i i think
have a have a tremendous opportunity and
i guess
i'd hope that we're able to learn more
about what the
university systems sort of strategic you
know
pivot is going to be um given that
particularly the
the available market through the
non-traditional
um students i i have a question
for joe or don or susan or catherine
um we when i'm looking at hb2
in front of me right now we're dealing
with governance
we're dealing with the makeup of our
structure and our organization
is there any kind of is has there been
any thinking
on the part of the university community
college system in terms of
timelines in which we're going to be
able to achieve
all these other policy issues that come
along with
a change of our governance and so that
the system can work
and be more affordable so it can be more
accessible
so it can meet the challenges of our our
our workforce that is forced demands
here in the state so
what kind of timeline are you looking at
i've heard susan heward talk about five
years for the community college system
down in connecticut
and they may have to extend that what
are we looking
at uh in terms of this and we are we
doing this in isolation
and not working new england is a very
small region it's the size of many
states
in other locations in our country and so
we're competing
with for example here i hear don burke
saying while we're introducing cyber
security well the university of maine
southern maine and gorham just
introduced the same program are we going
to have to start looking
beyond our borders several questions in
there
the the um susan you want to go first
sorry the the timeline the way we think
of the timeline is as follows
remember we're doing all this in crisis
um the the most
important two steps are
for each board to intelligently
the five most qualified representatives
to serve on that new board and there's
an equal burden on the governor
to pick one hopes from the existing
boards five really strong people
and then they immediately need to get on
with the task of selecting a chancellor
as quickly as possible and that person
you know back to representative miler's
question in crisis
given the scale of what we got to go
through it needs to be a ceo
um and uh now
then they will immediately assign
the their legal representative legal
counsel
who put to put together a draft of the
enabling legislation
while the board gets on to
[Music]
it's not a one-year task it's not a
three-year test it's not a five-year
test
it's a forever task the the
process of managing through
an unprecedented uh
time of change and challenge while
preserving
the higher ed missions of the
of the two-year four-year and graduate
programs
and uh some of it will be tran some of
it will be immediately obvious
you don't need two system offices
you don't need two procurement jobs you
don't need two it systems
um some of it is going to be um
is going to bubble up immediately i i
would think don
and his counterpart at white mountain
are going to be working on how they can
how they can coordinate their region
without any urging from the board
some of it is going to take years and
may never be worth it
for example a single accreditation it
may be that
maybe maybe in the north country you
gradually you gradually create one
unified faculty to serve that region
but other in other places is the totally
different faculty and a totally
different accreditation
you don't decide that in advance you
decide that as you go
you begin to understand partially based
on the financial pressures
what you need what you need to do and
how quickly you need to do it people on
the board
must be deeply committed to the mission
of public higher education for all the
citizens of the state
because they always have to put that
first so what do you do to preserve the
mission
while achieving financial viability and
and then the you know the sequence of
steps
uh be become apparent as you use those
as a guidepost but
if you don't have the right board you
don't have the right chancellor
since you don't have time everybody's in
real trouble
so i think this is the right approach
we just have to execute it right and
i'll repeat the same point
the best thing the legislature could do
for the citizens of new hampshire
with respect to public higher ed is give
this new group
a financial cushion rather than put them
in a position of having to figure out
how they're going to cut four million
dollars from
a combined budget in year two
and we've kind of tabled out what uh
what the bill calls for and so
the new board wouldn't be seated until
like the end of august they've got 60
days
to to be constituted and then
by january 1 they're supposed to have
delivered
information about what the new
um you know what the new entity is and
what the new statute
looks like if they're going to also
undertake a search for a chancellor
that's a year-long process and so as you
begin to look at it you've got lots of
things
going on at the same time and we don't
have what to me is
the absolute first thing which is what
is the mission
right so we need the mission first
we've got this statute that needs to to
be uh
developed and we've got a chancellor
or some sort of chief executive to look
for
all in a very very short period of time
conceptually the the you know the need
to
further integrate our two entities
it's just going to it's going to take
time and money
there are some initial steps i think
some of what don
has laid out makes sense i also
appreciate joe acknowledging the
regional
nature of new hampshire and so we may
you know five years down the road get to
a new place in fact
representative vlad the community
colleges still have not been integrated
so they started the work in connecticut
they started the work in 2011.
their very first attempt at getting
initial candidacy from netsch
is scheduled for 2023 and they are still
a heck of a long way
away from uh from that at this moment
so there there are partnerships and
teams that can be created
i appreciate hearing about plymouth
state and i have to say
it's white mountains with an s
because of where they are they're in
three different locations there
um and i and i do agree that the north
country needs that
western new hampshire needs something
too you know we look at the
high school graduation rates we look at
what's happening to students coming out
of the school systems there
they're not matching in many cases the
college-going rate of other parts of our
state and so
again the regional nature and what
portsmouth needs
very very different from what newport
for
instance needs or the southern uh
tier lots of really good questions
and there's a timeline here but a little
bit of planning
truly a lot of planning one of the
things i said to a previous committee is
you're bringing together two huge
entities yet there's nothing in the
in the in hb2 that says let's give them
some funding
it was a million dollars that was
devoted to the reorganization
that bea is undertaking for the regional
economic development areas 1.4 million
that was spent on dhhs
we are the future of our state we are
going to need
a financial commitment in order to move
forward with any kind of reorganization
[Music]
sorry
you're muted representative lad
go ahead catherine i was just going to
say
so um house bill 2 creates
one board to oversee
two systems until such time
as legislation comes back
for deliberation and passage house bill
doesn't in and of itself make
one system it ha it creates one board to
oversee the
i think the vision of house bill 2 is
there will be one integrated system
but house bill 2 in and of itself
doesn't get us there
it's that first step that's right
that's right representative milor
thank you rick um and thank you
for this very sobering
yeah analysis i mean i i'm
i knew about this but not
in the detail that you provided and i
really look very appreciative of this
i don't know whether or not there needs
to be a single board
governing these two systems but what
it's
very clear very clear
there needs to be somebody that's going
to begin to look at what is the mission
of higher education in this state
and whether it comes up with one board
governing all that that may be the
result of it
but everybody here all the presenters
have all talked about what's the mission
what's the mission of higher education
as we deal with the multiple
the multiple types of students and david
brings up the whole issue of the
different types of education the
different types of credentialing
we're beginning to look at a whole
different way
of what's needed out there and the
bottom line for me
is how is it going to impact the
workforce in this state and the economy
in this state
so for me as i look at this and again i
i'm still
stunned by the information that you've
given i'm really very appreciative of
that
is that what the board needs to do is
not look at how these
things are going to be combined
whether it's even relevant to be
combined but the question is
is how are we going to meet the needs
of the diverse population here
of students and if the result
of that review is one board
one system so be it
but i think that is down the road from
the initial look
of what do we need what is the mit and
i'm coming back to the mission again
because it is the mission that drives
the conversation
of where we want to go and that is not
that developing of that mission believe
me i know
because i've done mission statements
before is not an easy task
and it does take time and you're right
it needs to be funded
and if if if we think in this state
we're going to have this conversation
without some kind of funding to help
bring in their respective resources we
found that
in the study for the commission on
student funding
you need somebody from the outside that
can come in and help us have that
conversation that has had these
experiences
now granted those of you that presented
today
have a great sense of experience and i
really appreciate
from what you bring to the table here
but we need to have that conversation in
a way that is
beyond one system or gnosis multiple
system
we need to figure out what we want in
higher education
and that's that's what i'm taking away
from this conversation today and i'm so
appreciative
of the data you shared today it's very
sobering thank you
representative joe is that your hand up
yeah you know i i um
i violently agree with what you're
saying representative miller
there's a butt and the butt is
there is no tomorrow if we don't start
taking nobody wants to say this i'm just
going to say it i don't i don't have a
dog in this hunt i don't have an
i'm not an alumnus i don't have a member
of the family who's an alumnus of any of
the institutions
these institutions are going to start to
fail financially unless
unless the legislature is willing to put
tens of millions of more dollars in
we're on the cusp of several failures
and so it is it is
our duty collectively as citizens of the
state
to preserve the financial well-being of
public higher education
in new hampshire we got too much cost
spread out over too many institutions
so unless we're willing to say create a
board you have faith in
to manage through the financial crisis
and while you're doing that
then take on the very worthy
questions that you're you're raising and
you're going to need outside help
absolutely uh and but you've got to buy
it from breathing space
i mean you need to put the fire out in
the house before you can redesign the
kitchen
you know if we had listened to ross in
would be able to have the conversation
you're suggesting we have
before we move to something else we
didn't well some of
some some of you did um
yeah i some some did joe and i can
remember sean jasper
yelling the same thing um and
um and ross was very active in trying to
make us aware of what was what we were
headed into
and yes we're there now and yeah i don't
want to see
that 25 that's going to be eliminated
occurring here in this state so what we
need to do is we need to move forward
and i hear that from everybody that's
spoken today
that we we don't have any time
time is not on our side so are there
further
uh questions because i know we've gone
beyond our
noon hour i can see catherine being very
hungry there
and ready
nobody else with any questions i really
want to
thank our panel today uh it's been
enlightening
it really has been um to hear the
various
angles from our practitioners in the
school and those
that are on the the various boards here
it's enlightening and it's a little bit
a little bit scary that we are at this
position
and we we we're gonna have to do
something here so i appreciate it on
behalf of the subcommittee thank you
very much today
and if no other comments uh
i will call this meeting adjourned and
uh uh we will continue to work again
uh the next meeting we have is on friday
we're dealing with barbara brittenham
dealing with accreditation
and that's an issue that you know is a
resultant of
of of of uh the the
need to first look at the governance
here and i
and i am i'll tell you right now i'm a
strong believer that
any organization needs somebody at the
helm that's going to steer the ship and
make those ultimately you know the buck
stops here
so yep rick
yes you have a hand up yeah quick quick
question for you though
um just process going forward um what
are we
uh what are we looking to um uh produce
for a deliverable
and when yeah well you know we're we've
been asked
believe it or not we were of course i've
told you before that we have
we had a basically about a week and a
half
two weeks here for this whole uh uh
committee or sub committee work we have
to have a report
to uh division two finance
uh by the following by next week
so we're talking about on friday we're
gonna have
uh barbara brittenham come in and then
we're going to have to use the latter
part of that time and probably extend it
even
a little bit into the afternoon to uh
come up with our our findings our facts
we're not going to be taking any
specific
action uh we're going to be just
providing those policy statements and
that information
and what's uh needed uh by
karen umberger to make that finance
decision
to react to hb2
as they have to act on that hb2 bill
shortly thereafter we have to if we have
to go into the
afternoon i'm i'm prepared
uh to spend more time than just the the
morning shot here
oh i i i thoroughly expect that to
happen mel
okay good thank you yeah because this is
definitely happened
this is a huge topic and there's so many
issues
uh from the governance side right down
through all the policy considerations
and
uh it's huge and it's hard to believe
that we have to try to get that done
within a week and a half here
exactly so so given given that rick is
um is is jen helping us out with
um putting together draft findings and
stuff like that
well she's uh she's agreed to work with
us and support us in any way that we
need
and so yes she has uh uh the information
that for example the slideshow that was
shown by joe today
she has that that we will be delivered
to you
i would suggest that uh folks um
read those materials that have been
provided to us up to this point
become familiar with hb2 um so that when
we do meet later on on friday at 10
o'clock that
it most likely will i could see this
thing going to two o'clock in the
afternoon
easy easy quite quite easily quite
easily
we've done that it's not a happy thing
sitting in the same chair for that long
um so so that's that's where we are
um i want to again thank you to our
presenters today
um it you really uh opened i think our
eyes
to what we we have a a real significant
issue in new hampshire as well as the
nation does so
let's tackle it and get move forward
thank you thank you good to see you all
thanks